When we compare humans to the other great apes,
we see that they have a rather unusual life history.
These unusual features include large fat,
relatively undeveloped infants,
early weaning and short inter birth intervals,
slow development,
and extended childhood,
usually one offspring occasionally too.
And menopause.
We also have a life which is considerably longer than those of chimpanzees or
Bonobos
to see this concretely.
Let's take a look at two mothers.
One of them is named Emma,
the other is named Fifi.
Emma had 10 children in 17 years.
Seven of them survived and her inter birth interval was 1.8 years.
Her Age at first birth was 31 years,
pretty advanced.
Her agent last birth was 48 years,
unusually late.
Her Age at death was 88 years.
Fifi had nine children in 31 years,
almost the same number,
but it took her much longer.
Seven of them survived,
as did Emma's.
Her Inter birth interval was 3.9 years,
more than twice that of Emma's.
Her Age at first birth was 13 years much earlier.
Her agent last birth was 44 years,
not that much different from Emma's actually and her age of death was 46 years,
considerably younger than Emma's.
Emma is Emma Darwin,
Charles Darwin's wife and Fifi is one of Jane Goodall's.
Chimpanzees had gone bay.
Yeah.
If we expand that to look at the human life history in comparison with Bonobos,
chimpanzees and gorillas,
the things that really stand out are highlighted here in a heavier type.
Humans are heavier when they are born by almost twice the amount of the nobos
and chimpanzees.
They are weaned earlier.
The female age at first breeding is considerably later.
The average maximum lifespan is two decades or more longer and the Inter birth
interval is relatively short,
not that much shorter than Bonobos,
but considerably shorter than chimpanzees or gorillas.
The fact that humans are giving birth to offspring that need more care,
nevertheless are being weened earlier implies that in humans,
childcare is a social endeavor.
One person alone,
a mother alone could not rear this many children this fast.
Now let's start with the human life history,
uh,
at the beginning,
which is the egg.
This is an image of an egg in a follicle in the ovary.
The first point to make is that at three months of development of the fetus,
her ovaries are developed with about 7 million oh sites.
These old sites are progressively eliminated and by birth she has about a
million of them left.
Having discarded about 6 million and by men are a few thousand are left evidence
suggests that the defective ost sites are being preferentially discarded.
We also know that about 60 to 70% of concepted I or a boarded in the first
following Menzies,
many of these are not even noticed.
It takes a fairly careful study to get that kind of figure
evidence from Hutterite.
Women who have recurrent spontaneous abortions should suggest that the human
female reproductive tract is discarding concept die that are immunologically
deficient either because the paternal MHC illegals are too similar to the
maternal ones for the immune response to function or to avoid inbreeding
depression.
So the appear to be discarding lower quality offspring.
About 70% of conceptions that started as twins and is singleton births.
This is something we've discovered since ultrasound became standard practice.
All of these lines of evidence suggest that the human female reproductive tract
has been designed by evolution to function as a quality control device,
a selection arena,
the
as I go survives this implants and grows and is then born size at birth sets off
a whole series of trade offs.
Human birth weights range from one to four and a half kilos in length.
Human infants are 40 to 57 centimeters at birth.
Human babies have larger brains and they are fatter than babies that are born to
a similar size that chimpanzee or Bonobo relative to adult brain size.
Human babies should have even larger brains at birth,
but their growth is constrained by the diameter of the birth canal.
Therefore,
human babies continue brain growth and differentiation for a relatively long
time after birth up until about seven years of age.
This is related to the evolution of childhood and is a stage in our life history
that is lacking in chimpanzees and Bonobos.
The average birth weight of humans is actually about half a kilogram less than
the optimal weight infant survival.
This is either the result of current offspring conflict or have the constraints
of a narrow human birth canal.
Yeah,
low and high birth weight adversely affects survival,
health growth and mental development
and among other interesting natural history observations,
long thin baby girls reach men arc about six months earlier than normal short
chubby ones because they more than compensate with leader growth.
Yeah,
human growth patterns are very interesting primarily because they differ between
the sexes.
Human growth is target seeking and self stabilizing.
It is divided into five periods.
Infancy,
which is from birth up until about two years.
Childhood,
which is from two to about seven years.
When the brain finishes growing,
the juvenile period is from the beginning of puberty at about 10 years in girls
and 12 years in boys up until adolescence,
which continues through to full sexual maturity,
which is about 14 and girls and about 16 and boys and then adulthood and
adulthood.
Catch up.
Growth can continue in males up until more than 25 years of age.
Although most males stop growing as teenagers.
Yeah.
The growth patterns are different in the two sexes.
Childhood may be a feeding adaptation that allows shorter inter birth intervals
with family support.
Yeah.
The human adolescent growth spurt is uniquely large.
Chimpanzees and Bonobos do not have that kind of growth spurt.
Girls Look at adult and have men sees before they are fertile and they can in
day engage in adult roles without becoming pregnant for a year or two after they
appear to be adult.
Women voice produce functional sperm before they complete growth and develop
adult appearance,
so that is reversed between the two sexes.
Men are slightly larger than women,
possibly because of sexual selection
and women's store,
more of their fat in thighs,
buttocks and breasts.
Men are more muscular,
so there is sexual dimorphism in humans.
That's pretty standard
to emphasize.
The differences between the sexes.
Here are the growth velocity,
so the rate of growth with age for girls in red and boys in blue,
you can see that girls hit their peak growth velocity at about 12 and boys,
it's about 15
so they are differing considerably in the ages at which they achieve biological
maturity.
Okay.
Human patterns of reproductive investment are interesting.
The proximate factors that affect fee.
Kennedy Inter birth interval include nutrition,
stress,
marriage patterns,
breastfeeding,
contraception,
venereal disease,
conscious decisions in the presence or absence of the father.
All of those will affect inter birth interval and Fico Foundation.
Ultimate factors affecting fecundity and inter birth interval does it.
The evolutionary selective forces include offspring,
survival rates mediated by disease and nutrition,
the presence and absence of relatives and mates who help with child caring.
So this presence or absence of relatives and mates is something that developed
evolutionarily as part of human social life and it is probably on the order of
six or 7 million years old
mothers.
Fertility rates are trading off with intimate survival and that is shaping inter
birth interval,
short birth intervals,
endangered children who are at both ends because then there's going to be an
overlap of parental care between the infants.
Large families impose costs on two to four year old children and lactational.
Amen.
Maria regulates birth spacing to a certain degree.
As long as the woman keeps nursing,
she is less likely to ovulate.
One of the interesting patterns of reproductive investment in humans is
twinning.
Here are some identical girl twins and some identical boy twins.
4% of births are twins.
Twinning does pay in some environments but not in others.
It is more likely to increase fitness of both twins are girls
in food stress populations.
Twinning is maladaptive and it can be associated with infanticide,
which has been observed in hunter gatherer populations in both South America and
in Africa.
Ultrasound shows that about 70% of conceptions that start his twins and is
singleton births,
and that's another indication that twins are expensive.
It's almost as though up we made a mistake,
we need to get back to one rather than two and one of them is resort.
One Study of 20 done by your Luma and her colleagues showed that the Finnish
archipelago had a richer and more stable food supply than the finish mainland in
the 18th and 19th centuries.
They found that twins in the archipelago produced more than one adult,
but twins on the mainland only produced oh 0.7 adults.
Twinning was more common in the archipelago,
so the patterns seem to fit the survival probabilities.
Twin sisters were most successful.
Twin brothers were least successful.
Mothers of twins had higher mortality after age 65 because they were more
susceptible to tuberculosis.
So a study like this shows that there are trade offs between offspring number
and the sex of the offspring and the adaptiveness of having twins and also
between offspring number,
offspring survival and parental survival.
Now what about sex allocation,
which means the ratio of female to male offspring.
In terms of cultural effects,
we know that bride price societies limit the number of sons because sons become
expensive when they marry Dalry society's limit the number of daughters because
daughters become expensive when they marry where sons inherit the wealthy favor
sons and the poor favor daughters.
And that seems to be true in the United States,
Hungary and in Germany that would conform to the triggers.
Willard hypothesis,
which basically states that women could good condition,
should have more sons and women in poor conditions should have more daughters,
especially in any meeting system in which the sons need to be in good condition
in order to marry and have offspring.
But overall,
if we look across all of the studies that have been done,
the support for the triggers,
Willard hypothesis in humans is really rather mixed.
It's about 50% of the cases supported and about 50% do not.
Yeah.
Now,
what about lifespan in aging in humans
that we live longer than chimpanzees and bonobos might be the result of lower
extrinsic mortality rates that are caused by our social organization in our
group defense against predators.
You can think of that as self domestication.
Yeah.
That effect,
however,
is not large enough to explain our observed lifespan.
In addition,
we may have to invoke intergenerational transfers.
That is parental care and cooperative childcare,
mother and father effects and grandmother and grandfather effects,
all of which increased fitness contributions of older individuals.
So selection will act to extend lifespan if older individuals are having a
greater beneficial impact on overall fitness.
Now,
men can reproduce later in life than women if they have several marriages and
sequence.
Women will stop with menopause,
but men can keep going if they can then marry a younger woman.
So selection to prolong male life may then indirectly prolonged female life
because many of the same genes and regulatory networks are involved in
maintaining both sexes.
That would not explain why women stop reproducing at menopause.
Yeah,
so menopause is a bit of a puzzle.
After all in evolution,
fitness is determined by reproductive success and here women are stopping to
reproduce.
Why does that happen?
We know that chimpanzees do not have menopause.
Healthy females continue to have offspring right up until they die,
whereas in humans,
menopause is normal.
There are at least five nonexclusive hypotheses for the evolution of menopause.
As you'll see,
we don't actually know which or what mixture is correct.
The first idea is that it's about mothers.
Mothers stopped reproducing because the risk of dying in childbirth rises with
age and the mother must survive long enough to rear a child.
There's no point in trying to reproduce if the risk is so high that you'll die
and then the child will also die.
The second idea is that it's about grandmother's grandmother's can better help
daughters.
We are grandchildren if they do not have children themselves.
Intergenerational transfers can increase fitness contributions of older
individuals.
So the grandmother hypothesis really takes us an assumption.
Something like the mother hypothesis is a starting point.
Third it's about reproductive conflict.
Mothers in law or more related to their own offspring.
All o 0.5 then to those of their daughters in law,
they are related,
they're open to five whereas daughters in law are unrelated to the mother in
Law's offspring 0.0 and they are more related to their own oh 0.5 that means
daughters in law are under greater selection to quote when conflicts over
resources used for reproduction and that could select against continued
reproduction in older women in a fairly tightly knit society living in small
groups.
The fourth idea is that it's about offspring quality.
Essentially menopause is,
they're seen as a byproduct of selection for an efficient filter to eliminate
defective oh sites.
It occurs when the supply of ost sites is exhausted by a treasure.
This works if enough improvement in offspring quality early in life more than
compensates for reproduction,
which is lost late in life.
That fits fairly well with the evolutionary theory of aging.
But we have no direct evidence on it.
And then finally menopause is thought to be about self domestication.
So the idea here is that our social behavior,
our agriculture,
our culture improved survival,
extended lifespan and extended post reproductive life but did so without
increasing the supply of o sites selection.
Then modified the behavior of post reproductive individuals to enhance their
fitness by having them help to raise grandchildren.
So this actually combines the Austrian quality hypothesis with the grandmother
hypothesis.
The evidence is mixed.
The mother hypothesis,
the idea that mortality in childbirth increases with age only works as a
standalone explanation if the increase in mortality is implausibly large.
There is some evidence for and some against the grandmother hypothesis is a
standalone explanation,
but it does seem to work in combination with some of these others.
Yeah,
reproductive conflicts between mothers and law and daughters in law appear to be
real and they could contribute to the explanation,
but we have no quantitative measure of their effect.
Okay.
There is as yet no convincing evidence on the offspring quality hypothesis.
It's logically plausible but empirically unconfirmed.
The self domestication hypothesis also plausible and it rests on evidence for
both the offspring quality and the grandmother hypotheses,
which it combines.
Yeah.
These hypotheses are not mutually exclusive and some studies find combinations
of effects that will explain menopause.
It's hard to measure the relevant effects in the cultural and physical
environments in which the trade evolved that happened in the past and all modern
hunter gatherer societies that we can study are disturbed to a certain extent.
They're not necessarily representative of the hunter gatherer societies that we
ourselves came from in Africa,
Europe,
the Middle East and Asia.
Okay,
so to summarize,
the human life history has evolved to solve ecological problems are short,
inter birth interval is made possible by social help.
Yeah.
We are large and fat at birth with brains that will grow for seven more years.
That brain growth requires a lot of fat.
Yeah.
There are trade offs between the mother's Inter birth interval and offspring,
survival rates,
physical vigor and disease resistance
in males and reproduction and survival for females that are in poor condition.
Okay.
Menopause probably evolved for a combination of reasons.
We listed five that include at least mother,
grandmother,
reproductive conflict,
offspring quality and self domestication hypotheses.